una crisis sanitaria y de derechos
humanos la organización mundial de la
salud junto al consejo internacional de
enfermeras informaron que apenas 15 de
los 54 países del continente africano
han alcanzado el objetivo de vacunar
completamente al 10% de su población
contra el cob y 19
aplica ha recibido hasta la fecha más de
200 millones de dosis de vacunas y ha
administrado alrededor del 71 por ciento
de ellas
si actualmente 60 millones de personas
han sido vacunadas por completo lo que
representa poco más del 4 por ciento de
la población total de áfrica día total y
lesión
en áfrica
marks este jueves se marca la fecha
límite para que los países lograrán el
objetivo global de la oms de vacunar
completamente al 10 por ciento de su
población contra el cob y 19 el lento
progreso en la entrega de vacunas en
áfrica pone en riesgo la salud de
millones de personas los hospitales y el
bienestar de médicos y enfermeras
hemos escuchado a personas comprometerse
con la priorización de los trabajadores
de la salud en todo el mundo pero hoy en
día todavía hay enfermeras y
trabajadores de la salud esperando su
primera dosis de la vacuna en el
continente africano mientras que en
otros países las personas están
completamente vacunadas están recibiendo
vacunas de refuerzo y están
administrando vacunas a personas más
jóvenes también
lado ms pidió que las promesas de
donaciones por parte de los países ricos
se materialicen pronto e instaron a las
farmacéuticas que se hagan públicos sus
planes de distribución dando prioridad a
las naciones más pobres áfrica registra
hasta ahora más de 8 millones de
contagios por coronavirus de los cuales
al menos 200.000 han fallecido